even amongst Britain's glittering crime
Jewels one stone stands out it may not
be the world's biggest diamond but the
kui Nora's weight is measured Less in
carrots than in symbolism and bloodshed
featured in the coronations of Queens
for over a hundred years its absence
from Camilla's crime avoids a Minefield
of controversy but India it's become a
symbol of humiliation of colonial loot
it's this sort of diamond-shaped wound
in a psyche of a country that is trying
to still come to terms of how it was
ruled over by another country
instead Camilla will wear Queen Mary's
Crown which once held the Kohinoor but
no longer the crime has been removed
from its home here at the Tower of
London to be refashioned it will be
reset with diamonds belonging to the
late Queen Elizabeth II themselves rich
in symbolism but importantly without the
considerable baggage both present and
historical of the Kohinoor
the so-called cullinan diamonds were
often seen on broaches worn by her late
Majesty the queen consort have said that
she would very much like her crown to
reflect Queen Elizabeth II so many of
the diamonds that were regularly worn by
the lake Queen will be in their settings
in this Queen Mary's crime in her choice
of crime then Camilla is hoping to
embrace the legacy of a popular Monarch
rather than the much less popular Legacy
of Empire Matthew Thompson Sky News